can you maybe comment about Sachin
Adella and how hard it is for CEO to
sort of pivot a company towards open
source towards developer culture is
there something you could see about like
how what's the role of leadership in
such a
pivot and definition of a new vision
I've never met him but uh I hear
he's just a really sharp thinker
but he also has an incredible business
sense
he took the organization that had very
solid pieces but that was also
struggling
with all sorts of shameful things
especially the Steve Ballmer time
I imagine in part through his personal
charm and thinking and of course the the
great trust that that the the rest of
the leadership has in him he managed to
to Really Turn the company around and
sort of
change it from from openly hostile to
open source
to to actively embracing open source and
that doesn't mean that suddenly Excel is
going to go open source but that means
that there's room for a product like vs
code which is open source
yeah that's fascinating it gives me
faith that large companies with good
leadership can grow can expand can
change and pivot and so on develop
because it gets harder and harder as the
company gets large